à voir à commenter l'histoire l'histoire
de koh lanta c'était en 2001 la première
saison de koh lanta c'est votre ba ba
raconte sur koh lanta
sachez que ce n'était pas denis
brogniart qui était l'animateur de koh
lanta au début c'est un garçon qui
s'appelle hubert auriol denis brogniart
n'était que la voix off du programme il
faisait que la voie est la première
saison était programmée le samedi et le
dimanche
à 18h55 koh lanta c'est à 18h55 c'était
sur l'île de koh lanta la base l'île aux
millions dieu comme on l'appelait en
thaïlande et l'audience moyenne elle
était déjà de 4 millions trois cent
soixante mille à 18h55
ils ont vu que c'est un énorme carton le
concept a été créé en 92 le concept de
koh lanta la base il s'appelle survivor
1 aux états unis ça existe toujours
ils en sont à leur 40e saison regardez
la première finale le premier gagnon et
hubert auriol regardez c'est un autre
délire que denis brogniart c'est hubert
auriol le premier animateur regarder ça
sur cet îlot désert ils ne sont plus que
quatre deux femmes deux hommes
ils ont survécu à 40 jours d'épreuves
ces quatre rescapés se sont tour à tour
rallié trahi détester
en général vous êtes en phase finale
le conseil final s'organise voilà
l'ultime épreuve à laquelle devront
faire face guénaëlle et gilles voici
qu'apparaissent leurs 7 derniers
compagnons d'aventuré
[Musique]
g
s'il est donc le dernier survivant de
koh lanta les 43 jours de survie et des
preuves ont enfin rendu leur verdict
c'est le calme la gentillesse et le
grand sens moral de gilles qui sont
récompensés et denis brogniart on
reconnaît la voix enfin vous avez vu
c'est denis monière qui faisait la voix
off
c'est hubert auriol donc c'est un pilote
de course
voilà exactement regarder et dieu
bénisse à la chemise il est allé
l'acheter chez ben chemoul avantage je
bénis cela monsieur ses manches courtes
meslois rivaux au milieu deux poignets
vers la chemise claire à mon avis on met
extraire clvc du 58 c'est pas du tout ma
taille
ça passe tant l'aventurier excusé j'ai
ça doit être sympa tu as bien que ça
tout va
dieu bénisse la chemise du mérens
arabique alors aujourd'hui le concept
est adapté dans 39 pays et vous savez
koh lanta énormément voyagé l'amérique
du sud l'asie l'océanie en tout douze
destinations je sais que vous adorez un
baba raconte et la colle on t'a ce qu'on
retient bien sûr de koh lanta c'est les
épreuves mais c'est aussi les candidats
et koh lanta elle vit grâce à ces
candidats hors du commun et nous si on
devait franchement se rappeler d'un seul
candidat
ça reste quand même vous dire en 2003 il
apparaît à l'écran moundir il reviendra
en 2008 c'est le roi de la pop klein
regardez vous le dire pour nous c'est le
plus grand plus grands candidats de koh
lanta
moi je dis oui je fais vais c'est pour
gagner les 110 à une fois moi
et quoi je veux du ballon c'est la page
dans la gueule hier soir il dit il me
dit si par hasard c'est par hasard je
gagne et si par hasard j'ai gagné j'ai
souffrir la mer à pau payer ses dettes
photo choix toyota financial times du
jour j'y tiens ta femme décède parle pas
comme ça qu'ils sont bonnes à nîmes à la
pâte en deux mots je vous embrouiller et
on embrasse mon moundir oui benjamin
castaldi un quizz pour l'info faut se
rappeler qu'à l'époque tf1 et m6 étaient
en compétition pour acheter ce format il
avait fait incorrect et tf1 m6 pour ne
jamais lancé télé réalité ça s'est passé
entre taverne auquel pas de prôner le
sisto j'aurais l'époque le legs des
patrons de tf1
ils sont juré dans les yeux que jamais
ils achèteraient aucun problème de
pérennité
en sortant de leur bureau évidemment le
lay a signé koh lanta et c'est pour ça
qu'elle 6 à signer big brother devenu
love story et ben bravo maintenant à
catane et palerme a quitté sinon il y
aurait jamais eu de benjamin castaldi et
polenta ben voilà eh bien vous savez
quoi vous tombait bien parce que
justement on va parler de pêche et on va
parler un très belle prise de koh lanta
ce que koh lanta c'est la pêche ya une
belle prise en 2004 en 2012 et pourquoi
j'ai dit qu'on allait parler vous parce
que les deux plus belles prises il ya un
requin et une ré regardez
[Rires]
[Musique]
oh
bertrand a eu raison de se jeter à l'eau
ce pêcheur émérite a une nouvelle fois
visé juste
je parle du match
vit prenez dans lola
[Musique]
oui
et toi tu es parti comme s'enfuir
il a tapé
ouais l'apec
alors il faut savoir que la pêche
maintenant ce que je vous raconte bien
sûr des histoires pourrait réunir toute
la famille on vous raconte l'histoire de
koh lanta il ya une nombreuses
controverses sur la pêche que la
production est maintenant très attention
lors de la première saison
william un candidat a pêché plusieurs
bénitier géant qui sont classés espèce
protégée ou encore en 2005 en nouvelle
calédonie ils ont chassé certains
oiseaux espèces intégralement protégées
donc forcément ils font plus attention
aujourd'hui en 2007
grégoire est le premier sur sommes sans
doute le meilleur aventurier grégoire
n'est pas souverain rappelez-lui toi
plus moi plus tous ceux qui le veulent
me voir tout le monde n'attendait qu'une
chose et quand il a eu le malheur de
louper l'immunité
regardez grégoire s'est fait éjecter
c'est certainement le plus grand
aventurier de koh lanta haut niveau
voilà épreuve
il en a raté qu'une et il s'est fait
virer regardez mushkin grégoire c'est un
événement depuis la réunification
grégoire à risque pour la première fois
sans limite et qu'est ce que ça vous
fait grégoire d'entendre kevin durant la
victoire aux qu'est ce qui nous
importait c'était d'être devant grégoire
c'est pas digne et 7 bat grégoire c'est
fou ça voilà ça résume aussi un peu la
pression
l'objectif c'est pas gagné ses bases
grégoire c'est dur ça leur massacre man
ouest
pas évident
[Musique]
grégoire
grégoire prenez votre sac aller
récupérer votre flambeau et venez me
rejoindre
ils ont décidé de vous éliminer et leur
sentence est irrévocable
alors je comme je vous raconte
l'histoire de koh lanta dont ce soir
chez obama il paraît que denis brogniart
de son n'ai jamais revu
c'est le pire conseil de l'histoire de
koh lanta pour lui alors évidemment il
yal'arrivée aussi de claude en 2010 qui
était jusqu'à samedi
le plus grand gagnant des preuves en
individuel mettez oubliera vient de
détrôner la première participation de
teimuraz je vais je vais lui mettre je
vais je commente laurence benaïm vous
donner en 2007 et il fait des grilles de
des cris de guerre géniaux quand ils
gagnent dites le et hourras ouais bof je
préfère dire on t'aimera pour comprendre
les regards des enfants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et nous tous
à tous tantôt
il est bien bel et bien c'est beau et
ouattara il avait quelques grains
peut-être grâce à lui en 2007 c'est la
saison il ya eu le plus gros record
d'audience pour koh lanta la finale a
rassemblé 9,4 millions de
téléspectateurs en 2011 à part un
candidat maxime c'est le plus stratège
de toute l'histoire rappelez vous ils
avaient même fabriqué un faux collier
d'immunité qui ça c'était un ami normes
qui doivent regarder ça on n'avait pas
eu la première épreuve avec la
possibilité d'avoir décollé limité je
n'ai jamais eu cette idée là et puis on
se voyait peut-être encore des colliers
d'immunité cachée au sein de l'île donc
ce serait pas une grosse surprise si je
peux amener avec la qulité minutes et il
a donc préparé un incroyable coup de
bluff fabriqué un faux collier pour
tromper ses compagnons j'espère que nous
serons assez naïf pour penser c'est en
vrai donc ça va être ça va être marrant
de voir d'autres têtes
c'est quoi ça sert
il était là dedans oui il était là
dedans on en a vraiment été emballé deux
ans parce que dans d'autres cas c'est la
fête sans collier un faux collier
tu me déçois mais tu me déçois je suis
désolé de te décevoir sur le coup sur le
coup c'est sur la longueur il a fait un
faux collier et je vous le dis pour moi
le plus grand candidat de koh lanta
c'est en 2011 qui s'appelle jjg de
courtage et gégé voulais finir par cette
image de koh lanta avery il savait pas
nager
je crois que c'est un des plus grands
fous rires qu'on ait eue dans koh lanta
on regardait pour ceux qui sont avec
nous
regardez j'ai envie de dire chou chose
slip
non mais le slip et ouf non mais le shin
bet inse balade de devancer maghreb
regarder si j'ai dit ça c'est un grand j
j a touché la boue et les ils paniquent
et ils n'arrivent plus du tout avancé
par longtemps chez j'ai fait du surplace
il ne parvient pas à rejoindre le ponton
à la nage vous rappelle qu avant de
repartir il faut que gégé est passé le
témoin
olivier en profite pour apporter la 6e
qu'hier des rouges contre 5 pour les
jours gégé a fait de son mieux
il s'est rapproché du ponton mais il est
toujours en difficulté dans l'eau dans
la gueule les bruits des fois j'étais
comme ça
seulement aujourd'hui on trouve t'on
ceinture hulot est simple et un peu gros
sur la patate en g2 colotte a écrit
pionners voilà et le koh lanta je vous
rappelle bhl info ya plein de gens qui
réalisa sa série qu'il était étonné que
ça passe le samedi et le dimanche et
appelant qu'il estime attendait des
programmes pour il samedis et les
dimanches carbone avec ollanta à 19
heures c'est vrai que mine de rien
budget les budgets ont bien changé en
télé c'est incroyable